let's bring in Skies correspondent Katie
Spencer monitoring the development
outside their new broadcasting house so
did we learn anything more there from
Tim Davey do you feel Katie
I don't know I think it becomes each
time that we have these briefings from
Tim Davie now even more and more
frustrating can we just park for one
minute what he said in that interview
the fact that Tim Davey the director
General all of us broadcast Outlets from
other broadcasters have have asked for
interviews with Tim Davey we've been
told he's not giving any interviews if
the BBC is supposed to be open Fair
honest and and it is upfront about
what's going on to only give an
interview to a BBC Outlet to avoid
walking in any of the entrances or exits
here at the building for Tim Davey to
have gone in via the loading Bay to
avoid having to answer any of our
questions it just is it it Beggars
belief really that it doesn't seem to be
that certainly even in the interactions
that they're having with journalists
they're being honest and open and giving
people a chance to actually put
questions to the BBC the fact that this
q a press briefing was done via zoom
we're not in times of covert anymore and
yet the journalists weren't allowed to
speak directly to the director General
instead we had to tap out questions that
we of course couldn't ask follow-up
questions to when he avoided answering
our our questions that interview let's
dive into what he said there then
um he he said of the initial complaint
he wouldn't go into any specifics of how
that initial complaint has differed to
the response that they gave last week
after the sun published his article he's
again citing the fact that he has been
told the the BBC has been told by the
police to pause its investigation so
they're clearly going to use that as a
means of not explaining exactly in any
detail what differed from this initial
complaint to what district in their
response last week they've again
repeating these lines of it's all down
to duty of care it's all down to privacy
but they are balancing this up against
the public interest
um he set out the fact that the
investigations unit was under a a large
amount of pressure 250 complaints within
six months what is what he said but
again does that really offer any
explanation for the fact that all they
appeared to do was send one email which
didn't get a response and make one phone
call which didn't connect they didn't
even according to this log bothered to
follow it up with any other further
phone calls or emails a bit of detail we
do know uh that we didn't have from the
Press free thing that it was a a call by
all accounts that the complainant made
in the first place a 29 minute call and
judged from the recording of that call
is uh where the investigations team
judged whether or not This was um as
they do they were taking it seriously
but they didn't believe that there was
any criminality to this again he spoke
about how they will be looking at the
the protocols going forward uh that
whether or not they um things they take
red flag incidents or things a red flag
Tire up the chain quickly enough and
that I mean is the key from what we've
learned in the last couple of hours
clearly clearly they weren't moving
quickly enough when it comes to acting
on on things like this again
the uh Sarah Montague you highlighted
the fact that now the parents have hit
out and described the BBC as being Liars
for saying that they weren't told the
information
of the bank accounts and the
transactions he avoided answering what
information the investigation teams had
actually been told again Sarah Montague
asked uh whether or not they knew
whether the money for this young person
in questions lawyers was coming for the
presenter and the director General said
he didn't know where the money was
coming from but it wasn't something for
the BBC to comment on surely it is
imperative for the BBC to know whether
it is the presenter itself that is
paying for this Young Person's legal
fees
um and as well Sarah Montague pointed
out is it not a bit odd the fact that
the director General hasn't spoken to
this presenters on a six-figure salary
about exactly what's uh going on that
Tim Daley said it's not appropriate that
and instead it's a Senior Management
manager's role to to interact with the
presenter again I mean I I don't think
any of those uh answers that he gave
were particularly satisfactory and if
anything for all the journalists who are
trying to get answers it's just hugely
hugely frustrating